so first of all I loved this movie I
just love these kinds of movies where I
can actually like sit down and watch
this with my parents and like my whole
family and everybody you know will enjoy
it and for you Mr De Niro like my dad
would always like show me a lot of
movies like when I was like in high
school I remember him like showing me
the Deer Hunter and I he showed me like
The Godfather part too as well and it
was I was wondering for both of you was
there a movie that you know you that
kind of had a special place in your
heart because of like your parents like
showing you that or for me I think it
was Rocky uh Rocky to me was you know
I'm the type of guy I go see a movie and
I want to come home and be the guy in
the movie yeah so I saw Rocky I came
home and now I'm like Mom I'm gonna be a
boxer right or I would go see Superman I
want to be a superhero or what have you
but I think Rocky one for me was that
movie that my parents introduced me to
that I was like I wanted to be like just
alone I went to my father took me to see
uh thank you uh what the hell
well one was uh King Kong the original
King Kong
and then another was a cocktail movie I
forget
what the hell was it um like a French
art film anyway
um yeah so King Kong I was American
there are others but don't pull up the
top of my head this is in the early mid
40s late 40s yeah early 50s so you guys
did a Scorsese movie together now you're
doing you know like a comedy together is
there something what kind of movie if
you two were to work together again what
kind of movie would you want to do you
know next I don't know to me I I I'd
like to do a sequel to this one in
Sicily that would be a nice little uh
I'm pushing for this but
um yeah so uh I I don't I don't know I I
I don't know the answer to that question
other than I wouldn't mind doing another
one of these maybe you know he meets
meets a woman in Sicily or what have you
I don't know I would really flush this
out
so the thing is I know you uh met with
Salvo like forehand and you've worked a
lot you know with him he was on set but
I really want to know like throughout
the movie I'm like has he seen the movie
yet like yeah he saw the movie
he uh he was touched he was he was
emotional he definitely it was it was
surreal watching this movie with him and
I'm trying to put my myself in my
father's shoes watching this movie him
and De Niro playing my dad yeah what
what's going through his mind and uh and
just talking to people that have come in
to interview US I find that it's
resonating a lot with hey I saw my dad
in this movie my relationship with my
family so I like to hear that because it
means it's kind of resonating with
people in a real personal way I saw a
lot of my mother she was raised by a
German immigrant so a lot of that kind
of you know the culture clash and
everything like that I saw a lot of that
that's what it really
actually kind of helped like even just
make me laugh even more yeah
um so I also wanted to know did you
learn a lot about you know being a hair
stylist did you style a lot of hair for
the movie no I didn't do as much I mean
but Salva was helping me uh
do do what I had to do in the film and
it was great so yeah but I didn't go
take courses or classes and hairdressing
I didn't feel that I had to do that I
had him there he would help me we do
that and then it's just doing the the
business
um
with the dialogue and everything it's
it's not a technical thing but all those
things have to work and having that flow
and and also that you know that you you
look like you know what you're doing
yeah you make it your own as they say so
that was uh my what I had to do
absolutely loved your ponytail in the
movie
I was just you look great yeah that's
shallow too so I also want to know for
you Sebastian you have a lot of like
stand-up specials on Netflix for
somebody who maybe hasn't like seen your
stand up what is like a good one to like
start with uh well I like the like if
you saw them in order so you can see the
progression I mean the first one was
Sebastian live and then what's wrong
with people aren't you embarrassed and
then I figure what goes after that but
uh I think aren't you embarrassed is uh
is one of my best specials if I have to
reflect back on what I've done in the
past so yeah that's kind of a good
introductory I talk a lot about my
father and that's special I think early
on in my stand-up I wasn't really
getting personal with it I'd tell tell
you about hey I went through to Ross
Dress for Less today or I went here I
went there and then I started talking
about what's really personal to me and
that's when I started resonating with a
lot of people and I always hate the
saying when people are like oh they
don't make movies like this anymore but
for this they you really don't see a lot
of movies like this and it kind of
reminded me of like what came out like
even like when I was like in you know
elementary school and I would see like
comedians actually you know getting
movies again so I know you've worked in
television but um so how did it really
like come to be like Lionsgate you know
presented the opportunity to you or did
you kind of pitch it around or yeah
open the doors and so we love it and
we'd love to make this movie uh found
Laura to Russo the director who also
Italian-American the way she presented
we interviewed five directors and Laura
came in with a presentation that would
be
I I mean with visuals of what the people
are going to be wearing and how she saw
set pieces and this and that and the
other thing I'm like Jesus if she took
this much time to for the interview yeah
what the hell is she gonna do in the
movie so I I really resonated with her
also being Italian-American she knew the
world she she's got immigrant parents
herself so it was a no-brainer for me it
felt very like a personal movie it was
like there's nothing mean-spirited about
it and I really you know I really
appreciated that I even loved uh how you
make it almost like a romantic comedy
between you two especially you know when
you're like stopping the plane and you
know just hugging it out I'm like big
enough you know peck on the lips real
quick or something like that thank you
thanks for bringing it